hola mi nombre es susan font y soy un
director técnico de renderizado aquí en
pixar animation studios mi trabajo
consiste en asegurar que las imágenes
que ves en el cine se creen tan rápida y
eficientemente como sea posible y ese es
un trabajo muy importante porque como lo
describió christophe en el vídeo
anterior es renderizado es un proceso
sumamente complicado que requiere de
miles de computadoras todas ellas
trabajando juntas para renderizar
nuestras películas la granja de render
es donde guardamos todas estas
computadoras pero que exactamente es lo
que hacen estas computadoras es el tema
de esta lección en la primera parte
echaremos un vistazo geométrico a cómo
funciona un renderizado en la segunda
parte de la lección hablaremos sobre
algunos de los cálculos algebraicos y
ecuaciones que se necesitan para
escribir el código de un renderizado
como programa de computadora así que
comencemos
empecemos con una escena drásticamente
simplificada de op
este objeto habita en tres dimensiones
como podemos observar conforme navegamos
para explorarlo tal como ocurre al crear
películas de acción en vivo necesitamos
colocar una cámara dentro de la escena
en la computación gráfica llamamos a
esto una cámara virtual primero
seleccionamos una ubicación para la
cámara virtual que utilizaremos para
crear la imagen aquí se muestra en color
blanco también tenemos que decidir la
dirección en la que apunta nuestra
cámara eso se muestra aquí en rojo
enseguida levantamos un plano sobre el
que formaremos la imagen y representa lo
que verá la cámara virtual observa que
es perpendicular a la dirección de
visualización la pantalla se divide en
una cuadrícula de píxeles que compondrán
la imagen en este interactivo los
primeros dos deslizadores te permiten
girar tu cámara alrededor de la escena
el trabajo de renderizado suena sencillo
debe determinar un color para cada uno
de estos píxeles
esto es algo así como la pintura por
números donde el plano de visión sirve
como el lienzo sobre el que pintara el
renderizado ahora bien en este ejemplo
solo te estoy mostrando unos cuantos
píxeles nuestras verdaderas imágenes
están compuestas de más de 2 millones de
píxeles a lo largo de los años se ha
desarrollado un número de diferentes
algoritmos de renderizado uno de los
algoritmos más elegantes y versátiles se
conoce con el nombre de ray tracing y
funciona así para determinar un color
para digamos a este pixel un rey kleiser
construye el rayo matemático que empieza
en la cámara atraviesa el centro del
pixel y luego se extiende hasta la
escena algo así como un rayo láser
apuntando hacia el píxel pero desde la
cámara el rey fraser calcula el punto de
intersección más cercano entre los
objetos de la escena y este rayo
a continuación determina el objeto inter
secado en ese punto y pinta el píxel de
ese color
entonces este pixel se colorear y a de
café este de amarillo y así
sucesivamente para los demás píxeles
este proceso se realiza para todos los
píxeles de la imagen existen versiones
más elaboradas del rey tracing que
pueden crear efectos más sutiles como
sombras difuminadas y variaciones de
iluminación que ayudan a crear
diferentes estados de ánimo el proceso
de ray tracing conduce a un montón de
otras preguntas como cómo se determinan
los puntos de intersección y una vez que
se determine ese punto de intersección
cómo podemos averiguar de qué color es
estos misterios y más se revelarán en lo
que resta del tutorial en este primer
ejercicio puedes practicar algo del
racing por ti mismo